hello and welcome to this video playing
international master broker nope and no
information no history against this
player I'm just going to play for
Russell D more Sicilian and I'm playing
it by ear but always sell that this is a
kind of comfortable position for white
let's see what he's doing trying for
some f5 I guess well so i'm at five I
can prevent okay hmm if i go here isn't
he right he'll probably go back right
jack nope it does not go back I would
have thought that this is the way to do
it anyway so here this is this typical
situation the pawn structure is fixed
and I'm going to try for f4 here it's
easier for why it to play avoid this
position then put black top layer 5 this
is some what White's play is based upon
at least part of it so what do I poder
do it 95 maybe an f4
I wasn't sure if a 4 would have been
helpful to play okay
interesting I can just take not sure if
I want to do I have something else I
have five also in this position could be
interesting five pawn takes rook F a
Droog f8 Quincy three something like
that
not sure it doesn't doesn't look bad
that isn't a chick somehow I thought
that is a check but doesn't matter I
guess
you're threatening rook takes e5 now
also probably to take is six and rook
takes you five those are threats you can
play the king of course but I thought
that after taking only five I'm probably
a little bit better I have 94 as an idea
okay ambitious
check
very ambitious play public okay I have
to check if I check here it's got king
of six unfortunately 96 takes rook
chicks that's probably a draw h4 is a
most maybe h phi is got my king of six
is not helping him that much let's see
can you have six i can just move the
rock
threading okie 70
c5 now looky some [ __ ] f7 is still ok
for him
Kim probably still nothing much
I'm not quite sure somehow though we
should play it now if he goes k
interesting
check king of six rupee seven what's the
idea you can click first or I think I
take here first
cannot cover b6 now check so if i take
here you've got rook c8 i think i have
to take here first
rook c8 I think Roxy for should work
King a for king of two you just took it
now it's probably rather dry time
morning
I'm going to several other to offer draw
him
game drawn nothing much it's nothing
much I me I had some chances in this end
game that ok a computer just just takes
the porn yeah maybe I can just take the
pawn yeah I like the idea of threatening
but this is just working it just saves
the day for him age 6 you're thinking
maybe he has something night h2 was
better okay yeah yeah what I did not see
is is that he my porn is actually
hanging on f3 and that means we had just
have er yeah the sequence of captures
channel after which not much is
happening so I wonder something better
over here for tix looked interesting now
there is an interesting move which are
thought about but I actually made a
mistake I didn't look further because
now he cannot take the keurig remove the
rook because of 96 it's quite
interesting I mean I'm not winning or
anything but something I could have
could have gone for interesting okay
this is how it went and it's probably
okay like if he does not play Queen d4
can be a discreet see for the real deal
is I have to take I already just have to
take the pawn one point is that here i
can actually Hague and it looks pretty
awkward my night has no
squares but the engine shows no mercy
and just goes here and hide winds may be
tricky okay well thanks for watching